Brazil is the world's fifth largest country...
...stretching out over 8.5 million square kilometers.
With some 200 million inhabitants, it also ranks fifth in terms of population.
The national flag reflects Brazil's diversity.
Its green background symbolizes nature.
Forests still cover 5.5 million square kilometers, nearly 2/3 of the country,...
...despite significant deforestation.
The yellow diamond represents rich natural resources including gold.
Brazil is a major world player in agricultural production and mining.
The blue globe illustrates the sky.
Its 27 stars are for each Brazilian state and the capital Brasilia.
The national motto "order and progress"...
...was inspired by French philosopher Auguste Comte.
Its inscription follows the line of the equator.
Underneath, the southern cross five-star constellation...
...is a reminder of Brazil's location in the southern hemisphere.
The sundered flag's globe also symbolizes football's importance in Brazil,...
...although the country's never taken top honors for the sport in the Olympic games.